Mình chỉ thăm mồn yêu cơ quan chuyên thân khó tế tụi trục trọng đưa tin,
về nè làm việc đông tin của đại hội đề biểu tòan Quốc lần thứ mấy bốn của đàn,
sự kiến chính trị trọng yêu, sinh xa từ ngày mình chỉ đến ngày hà năng thăm mồn tại thủ đô Hà Nội.
Hán thông tần Ape nhấn mạnh, đại hội thu mua khoảng 1 in sống trong đại biểu,
tập trung bầu trọng lãnh đạo cấp cao và định hướng phát triển đất nước,
dở đoạn tới, dở bối cảnh kinh tế thuần cầu nhiều biến đạo.
Theo hẳng Ape, đại hội cũng được đồng của tế đánh giá là cơ hội,
để viên em khẳng định một tiêu trở thành nền kinh tế thu nhập cao vàng giữa thế ki,
đồng thời ứng phó về tất cả tự cạnh tránh trị lơ của vực.
Mồ tháng thông tần lớn khác là Rồi Tơ s cũng được tin,
đại hội biểu bốn sẽ đình đường lối chính xe quan trọng,
nhưng một tiêu tăng trường vinh tế và cùng cố an ninh Quốc phòng.
Rồi Tơ s đồng thời gian một mồn nội dùng,
khoan nènh tổn bị thư tố lâm, nhưng một nhà lãnh đạo giám nghĩ giám làm,
cho bố cạnh đất nước nỗ lực cả các cạnh trính và thủ nút đầu tự nước ngoài.
Trà nơi đây liy thì nhấn mạnh,
đại hội dính ra khi Việt Nam nổi lên là điểm sáng tăng trường ở đồng nè,
chỉ sổ liệu cho đếp đây tăng trình táng phần chăm và nhận đình,
đại hội đường khó học công nghệ đổi mới sáng cảo,
vào chung tâm chỉ lực phát trình của ra.
Chứ đó, vâng người bốn tức mồ tại như nhau,
Mỹ đại xưa đấu hùng viện,
chừng phải đoạn từng trường Việt Nam tại liên hủ Quốc,
đã chùi chi với gặp ngớ và thục tình cho báo chi của tế,
về đại hội đẹp biểu tăng cốt lên thứ mấy bốn của đảng cộng sản Việt Nam,
thô sự quan tâm từ hàng chục hàng thùng tần lớn,
New Bruters, CNBC, Le Mong,
Aung Zerzeo Rang,
Em Nghe Hát Cà, Nhi Kee, Tân Hoa Zan,
CCTV, VIA, Năm Bóc Tee, Hải Tà,
các ông tin trên phản nánh đồ quan tâm rất lớn của cộng đồng đi giới,
đối với định không phát triển và chính xích đối ngoài của Việt Nam.